demande physio jose promotion détective
un géo trouvetou propos portent à
palisson qu'inspecteur squeeze l'homme
de la situation
huawei a dit ok je ne vais pas c'est
parti pour une nouvelle enquête
d'inspecteurs squeeze
ok c'est parti on est actuellement le
détective et en gros on doit trouver si
la personne à qui on parle est un robot
aussi c'est une vraie personne et l'eau
déjà on dit bonjour puisqu'on est poli
et l'eau ok peux tu pensé ça ça me met
sur la piste pipe détective un pipe
bebig donnons bipper au bout ça tu aimes
la chantilly si c'est un robot
techniquement il n'a jamais mangé de
chantilly soi afin de répondre il va
bloquer vip est ce que tu peux dire
autre chose que bip bip bip détective
c'est une blague c'est une comédie ou au
quai comme c'est forcément un robot
c'est sûr et certain qu'ils aient toutes
humeur favori ivy quoi c'est qui y vit
clc qui y vit se trouvaient les fans de
dc comics et parle de paulson et vie de
cette femme là bon allez aille pas comme
ça dans dc comics bip bip
ok on passe aux choses sérieuses marc
leval adn
y'a plus qu'à mettre dans la machine qui
scanne et hop un des années gaz quizy
[ __ ] [ __ ] je le savais ça nous
avance pas c'est 6 de ning m
tu fermes ta gueule tu fermes ta gueule
quitte à les relever laden n'ont pas
marché comme on va faire un bébé
détective j'en ai marre j'en ai marre
l'inspecteur squeeze par son cadre
exposé hockey que j'ai une question qui
est ton perso préféré dans futurama
voyez où je veux en venir je ne sais pas
tu es sûr il est métallique allen est
wafeer laisse toi aller dans le piège
peut-être mais je pense que je ne suis
pas sûr parce que je sais ce que je suis
bebig détective tu contourne la question
gamin ça c'est lé prof sévère qui a vu
juste comme ça et 1,8 sur qu'est-ce que
tu bois
dis moi tu es plutôt aux boissons
sucrées ou plutôt essence sans faire
marcher son moteur de robots y vit ivic
mr vie mister ville au rail
tu bois du rail
ouais théorique intiale et aux films
préférés ce n'est pas par hasard ironman
robocop transformers prout 1
aimes-tu la mécanique jaxx tu es occupé
répond à la question
bip attend ce soir vannes il veut qu'on
le bipe se trouve juste qu'on le bipe
mais où on va le bipper
voilà on habitait alors ta hockey en
sont les lunettes qu'on ne sort que dans
les enquêtes très très difficile j'en
appelle aux lunettes vanasse ça alors
et tu as un robot un humain on va droit
au but j'en ai marre de toutes ces
conneries je suis moi est un humain
attendez attendez je crois que j'ai
trouvé sony sony la lettre aux lettres
on ressemble au bouton rouge de synthés
ce synthé si on fait au mob à gauche
droite
ils s'envolent en vol e n 0 et elle peut
en vol - six lettres l ar putté aussi
laide si laide comme 41 capucins 5,5
sinon de la tzigane en robot pas aux
cellules en vérité tu es un robot
correct
c'est dû à la fin de cette vidéo un peu
facile on va pas se mentir
n'hésitez pas allez mais ça vous a plu
si vous voulez faire appel à mes
services mais honoraires sont dans la
description c'est extrêmement cher voilà
c'est parce que je suis hyper content
c'est une enquête de plus nulle part
inspecteurs squeeze et on peut tomber
sur un joueur c'est ça le délire c'est
que ces soins robot soit un joueur pour
de vrai c'est pas à chaque fois un robot
permet je vous vois dans mon cas et
c'est le christ classe quizy là vous
êtes ont commencé après inspection que
moi j'ai mon master enquêteurs à
l'attrait de moi je vais me refaire ses
regards des plus parfaits minutes tout
au plus